hey guys it's december twenty second I'm
chastity and this is the very last
gamespot news of the year but before we
refuse the latest
[Music]
first up the new god of war ps4 game
reaches a milestone sony announced a new
god of war game for ps4 during e3 this
past summer but we haven't heard much
about it since it was absent from PSX
this month too there is no reason to be
concerned according to director Corey
bar log responding to someone on Twitter
who said they gave up on waiting for
news about the game bar log revealed
that it recently crossed a milestone the
game is now playable start to finish or
at least some version of it there's a
whole game here he said in response to
someone who joked that the game might be
limited to the deer hunting sequence
from the reveal trailer he added just
finished the first full playthrough with
the leads very exciting milestone for us
the new god of war is set after the
events of the third game and it won't
feature an open world though bar log did
say it was quote open it also won't
feature the original Kratos voice actor
TC Carson the role has instead been
taken over by Stargate sg-1 actor
christopher Judge additionally the new
god of war will not feature any
multiplayer no release date has
officially been announced next details
and mine crafts new update for consoles
the latest update to hit minecraft for
consoles is now available bringing the
console version too near feature parity
with the pc version minecraft 1.4
consoles is now available making
significant changes to end game content
adding more life and character to the
otherwise bland final area of one of the
most popular games on the planet players
can also now get Elektra a chestplate
slot item that gives the player wings
while equipped players can glide from
high ledges until they reach the ground
controlling their rate of descent by
looking up or down while a small amount
of altitude can be gained by looking up
players will stall if they do so for too
long Elektra cannot be crafted only
found in the end update 1 point 10 also
adds brewing new tutorials for banners
in Elettra and status effects such as
levitation and luck and finally the huge
Xbox Live sale has begun here are this
week's deals
as announced previously there will be
more than 350 deals throughout the sale
which runs through january 9th there
will be daily and weekly deals the first
have now been confirmed today's daily
deal as of December 22nd is on the life
is strange complete edition which is
going for just five dollars in terms of
weekly deals some of the Xbox one offers
available now include Arkham Knight for
ten dollars battlefield one for
thirty-nine dollars Dishonored 2 for
forty dollars and titanfall 2 for thirty
dollars go to gamespot com to see a full
rundown of all the xbox one and xbox 360
weekly deals head over to gamespot com
to read about steams winter sale and by
the way this is the last gamespot news
of 2016 Jess will be back in January
with more news I'm chastity and you can
find me over on gamespot universe and
that's gamespot's home for TV movies and
comics that's our permanent home for
entertainment videos as a January third
so subscribe and never miss a video I'll
see you next year take care